okay good evening everybody
extend to several monkey start I'll
start by reading the emergency
evacuation should we be imported to
evacuate the building to please leave
the building by the US painful exit then
one fire exit through the external
staircase if anyone is unable to we'll
be in before we get to agenda by someone
just welcome to everybody nice to see
some familiar faces back on the review
committee and welcome to some new
members of the committee as well enjoy
from here at the bring new committee
start by agenda item number one
apologies for absence
we have apologies for me counselor meal
and counselor Mountain item number to
substitute members counselor mrs.
Gooding for counselor meal and counselor
mrs. Mason
of interest but this has come about from
the voice of the tunes on areas that
[Applause]
thank you first of all I just like to
thank my predecessor it's going to be
quite a hard act to follow but I will
from time to time before it on
somebody's expertise one thing that you
will quite often hear me say as I go
through a period of time is two words
proactive and inclusive I'm looking for
the council to be far more proactive and
wherever possible to be far more
inclusive some of the things that I
would like to see the review committee
perhaps looking at about one or two
suggestions and obviously the other day
it's up to you guys one or two things
that are happening beyond say most of
using be aware of is the 2020 operation
these events that are coming forward I
know they're working very hard on that
there was a couple of meetings today
those regards
the asset review which we've had a very
good strong working party your
vice-chair has been part of that you may
want to consider having a look at that
various aspects from them on the outside
slightly looking at the 2050s ler
program that is coming forward which is
a joint operation or joint program of
strategic matters going right the way
along the South Essex and of course I'm
sure most of you but we aware that I'm
personally working on the one to seven
economic corridor one area which i think
is would be good to review is the
emergency plan that needs to be reviewed
from time to time
new things come along things change so I
think that needs to be looked at one
thing that I did notice that was on your
your list
that's called all very kindly let me
have a copy of is with regards to the
cutbacks that's something that I'm
actually working with the portfolio hold
on and we're looking to set up a working
group and should be a cross-party
working group to look at the car parks
from the point of view of are they
providing the right service how good
they are how well they run have we got
the right type of spaces one of the
things I often hear is that people are
asking for mother and child spaces as
well as disabled so look at all of those
particular revenues so we are working on
that side of things so I notice on your
list there perhaps I talk too much
outside of this meeting Silicon Valley
one that I'm very keen that perhaps we
for assistance for you to look at is how
green we can't have the cancer is
councillor Gooding and first mention
this to me give me a little bit of
thought with regards to a notice that we
have single-use cups here I suspect at
least getting more than one use have
been on their top of those bus for some
considerable time looks like perhaps
that just needs a review on itself yeah
so they look to look at what the counts
of itself is doing something that my
fellow County Council's will be aware of
the county we've gone through quite a
big review like that for example the
restaurant now so they're using plastic
nicer forks
they either provide metal ones or if
you're taking away they provide wooden
ones the coffee machines for example
that we had a County they used a plastic
Chasse inside the thing so they've now
replaced the coffee machines so it's all
of those particular aspects perhaps to
extend that even further how green is
our electrical supply for example we get
in our electric from renewable sources
is it would it be cost efficient for us
to do that
what are the other things is with
regards to new developments coming
forward this is something that I
particularly clean on the scene is with
new developments we look at attenuation
systems that are looking after the water
runoff from the various greenfield sites
that to me would be a good source of a
great water system so could that be used
on a new developments for prey water how
do we go about encouraging developers to
use those types of types of ideas for
example when we were looking at the
freight house redevelopment there we've
got quite a large reservoir next door I
would like to see and has been mentioned
working party the brain water system in
the new council offices sources is water
from the reservoir it's a supply of
water why are we wasting good clean
water when there's a sufficient water
day I believe the reservoir was there
originally to supply water for the steam
engine so I don't think we get too much
competition on that point there so
that's one of the thoughts that I've had
the perhaps the review committee might
like to have a look Thank You mr.
chairman I think that's quite a
comprehensive list of items for this
committee to consider but what you
haven't given us is your plans for the
forthcoming year miss your plans are for
this committee to do all this work on
behalf of the council so the intention
of this was that we both heard the plans
morally for the coming year as well as
any suggestions for this committee to
work so could you clarify the other side
of your work plan case well business as
usual really I think he's probably the
first person to say but as I've already
mentioned I want to be far more
proactive in all the things that the
council is done including the written
review committee and be more conclusive
one of the areas that are looking at is
the executive meeting for example and
how we can make that a little bit more
inclusive for non members of the cabinet
so I'm working currently with the legal
team on how we can perhaps take a fork
and can't say too much at the moment
it's a lot of Hector legal opinion so
there's some things I would assume that
would be changed to Constitution it
would mean council but I mean at the
moment you're aware that members can't
even ask a question so very odd place to
say that yeah so it's those sorts of
things that I'm looking into it so that
that's your plan is that your
suggestions for us of this long list
I just might offer you some of the
students don't have to do
we were all Thank You chairman all
teachers to sort of articulate in
reinforce I think that the comments that
cancer stepped is made and to reflect on
the the point and question from counsel
mrs. Mason you know I think that the
work program over the next year
I mean clearly there is there that
there's the business as usual the the
development of the MTFs and and you know
the relief financial strategy for the
council but I think in terms of these
have already been raised the asset
strategy is clearly an ongoing piece of
work key piece of work for the council
over the next two months we've got
rights for 2020 festivals been mentioned
the work in relation to the South Essex
authorities and six twenty fifty years
is an ongoing piece of work so I think
you know there's within the list there
are a number of items that are key
pieces of work quite strategic for the
for the Council of the next twelve
months
thank you just come back on that my only
concern on on that these items is that
we're meant to be scrutinizing the
decisions that are made not making the
decisions and I think there's a fine
line there and we need to be careful not
to cross that but other than that I'm
perfectly happy to consider any of these
items Thank You chairman them either
officer pointed out the asset review is
part of the ongoing work in any way I am
very interested in the suggestion and
they are only suggestions they put
forward to look at the green side of
that because there's no doubt but we're
going to make a substantial savings but
if we can reduce our carbon footprint
that not only add to the savings but
also have the effect on the environment
which is naturally ended and I'm also
interested I'm asked to make the
emergency plan and have set them a
little bit selfish but the area I
represent is in a very I think in
particular when you mention the results
of that just by shoot I mean you
mentioned a few things in it overall I'm
assuming that significant savings can be
made or I can't quite your fears not
being personally that involved with it
I'm just relating to where we started to
think that ideas Julie spoke to me and I
started to add two and two together but
for example in the council chamber we
had plastic versions of this and plastic
cups so when you think the 75
councillors that's quite a considerable
number over the period of time that's
quite a lot I couldn't give you what the
price of those are but so there's quite
a substantial to say and of course
you've got to bear in mind that right
across the whole of the county I think
it's something that Terry O'Quinn yes I
need the reason 2,000 employees I think
you put in there so at least better 5700
actually employed if you include things
like cleaners etc when you get tired and
I thought gets an aside that also
extends out to the schools as well as
the other the council's offices
themselves thank you also you mentioned
about the 2020 which
beware of a hurdle can you just give us
idea what kind of where that is at the
moment or anything well there was a
meeting this morning which are afraid I
haven't had in that day from so I can't
relate to their I didn't know that
they're talking to a quite a number of
organizations I happened to bump into
the chat from a Shinto Minster this
morning and he was in attendance there
but they are looking at a number of
things working with a considerable
number of other smaller groups doing
things Ward one of the the items which
struck my attention was that I'm sure
you're aware that the Bayeux Tapestry
has connections to Essendon the the
vicar that was there is actually on the
biochemistry and there is a group that
is going to put together a small newer
version of the bad crafty in modern
times so it's those sorts of projects I
was actually animating swimming a lot of
big things we did with that tapestry was
a group of women I've got the material
for them I've got the threads for them
and some other bits to it they're just
waiting for certain part work to be done
and we say it's got to be done by the
end of this month otherwise it's not
very well it's gotta be enough time for
as Mike said Angela
ideas were thrown around what we needed
how to get funding for parishes to let
Angela know effects are happening within
the area around the time period so it's
late and for us as counselors once so
that everyone know what is happening and
if they can please advise the RDC what
they doing also so it can be advertised
in a proper manner because he's long to
Facebook they've got Twitter page there
you go we've got an offer of events of
so after a whole district over the
weekend they had the Trinity and English
demo which right through two small
events in the smaller villages and it's
Canal coordinating some sort of those
means one item that I'm quite keen on
and the number of members will be aware
of know exactly what I'm about to say is
I'm quite keen to see things like chest
for example the challenge I've been
given is if there is just one point
Cherry Pie through you and as far as
being green is concerned I know some
councils have actually got their their
freight liners there for the recycling
collection vehicles running on fuels
that are recyclable like you know the
sunflower oil times deities yeah so is
that something could be looked at
because it we might be able to do it at
no cost of freedom constraints so is to
do it for us yeah so they might help
their image as well so then something
that we could possibly persuade
short might like to mention
I believe we have we actually are
awaiting delivery of an electric truck
or van you know as one of the
replacements of the police so actually
you know interesting to see how that how
that works within there within the fleet
so you know that's a step forward I
think you know and ultimately if that's
successful I guess we replaced it we
only have we only have a small number of
vehicles would replace them all with the
electric I think becoming more green is
quite a big challenge it's quite a big
subject that's right like I have seen a
review committee involved with that now
from the point of view of how we operate
ourselves and how we try to encourage
others to operate within that as well
through YouTube just to say that I know
that the government is quite keen I
think the outgoing Prime Minister shall
we say made it clear that there would be
money available to go green and carbon
neutral I'm just wondering if if there
are grants coming forward and for
certain things that we make sure we take
advantage of them where we can confer
instance the electrical charging points
that we spoke of it depending last week
yeah you know that sort of thing is
coming forward so where we can get
grants let's make sure we get our
applications in yes we're not going to
get everyone but let's see if we can get
as much as
you know I'm tied into the car parks you
know the green charging points in the
car Thank You mr. Boyd Thank You
chairman
yeah I think so done interestingness
which we may or may not choose some
proposed I think the problem is summer
white would have to act quite quickly
2020 for instance is happening
effectively so I'm not sure how much
usually reviewed which you could be
doing that for instance and then you go
to the other extreme that's how green
it's caocao and that's like an
open-ended review really isn't he
you'll keep on doing that the only
aspect I'd like to say obviously of
query some things already which may or
may not be aware of but I've been I have
asked again some of these open
atmosphere that how green is council
throw open up with the answer review yes
because one of the preachers who asked
about the development of the freight
house is that going to be zero carbon
not being topped No so I'm very dishes
say for example so many things singing
they only like for my baby but yes that
certainly will be looked at but whether
it be zero carbon with these perhaps
that I'm sure we throw the review
committees previous go to the emergency
no nothing that's probably Burton darker
a standard thing that we do I believe
going back onto the leaders points that
the being green are wondered I don't
know if this is the correct arena but
I'm also interesting to see how we could
escalate up the businesses in Watford
district to encourage those to become
greener first you think you need to lead
from the front
do you think we need to put our house in
order if you like okay and then we can
say the businesses look this is how
we've done it and these are the ideas to
take forward so you know it's no good us
going out banging on the doors business
and say you've got beef
we're not and it's not thanks thank you
while we were on the green issue Sun I
think it was seven years ago actually it
was proposed that when the planning
documents were being looked at that we
asked for solar panels on all new
buildings that the council refused to do
that so I mean we have lost
opportunities in the past but that it's
something that could be done very simply
and by the portfolio hold and very
quickly and the same with the gray water
gray water can be done so that hates
okay team
there is a problem with solar heating in
some of the systems that they're putting
in I'm know because my son has a past
with what they're putting in a very
complex overly complex six systems and I
know that cuz I've got a house with
solar heating which is a very simple
system and they usually they can work
with a backup immersion it's just a tank
but they're no expensive for the
building stage to put in than they are a
conventional system but they're much
cheaper Terrell just but it says my
son's got a four-bedroom house his
electricity bill is around seven pound a
quarter so that would give you an
indication of the posting one property
doesn't use much electricity but the
sensor does that feed onto national
breeders will take on his face on as
well he gets money from his work but I
haven't asked him how much but I'd
really substantial but having said that
I don't think the financial situation is
the be-all and end-all I think the the
carbon imprint is the most important one
if we insist that our new bills have
that dual system where you've got a
solar panel system and that can be
overridden by an immersion heater which
is the simplest way then we could we can
do that we don't need anything more it
sits within that within the power
particularly we've already spoken to the
funny however on those particular points
but it's those sorts of things and where
we need to go forward from that because
as time moves on
I forget who was it descent me something
the other day you often see these
windmills which are quite complicated as
a build and very expensive but there's
this new type which is just looks like a
post and it was and that in itself
generates electricity they are there no
I say again I don't know so those sorts
of things that show how far into the
future should we be looking just
terminate it I don't understand the
depth and the spirits on this issue
because I think I think it's important
but I think was a and I think it's
something that does need further
exploration but it's important to note
that the finding policies that the
council did seek to implement in the
past were very much along the lines of
saying you know there needs to be in a
high environmental performance for for a
new dwellings in particular but it also
applied to employment and commercial
buildings and and actually the current
state of plays that the government took
that responsibility away from planning
authorities and say hold on a second
that's an issue that should be dealt
with through the technical aspects of
the building regulations and the
building regulations set out the
environmental performance of new homes
in I think there's an issue there too
you know the discussion still to be had
but I think it's just important to note
that it's not as simple as just saying
to a developer
hey you you'll stick solar panels on
because from a planning condition
perspective you know we're not going to
be likely to be able to do that
I think it's least exploring then no I
mean I can't disagree because I think
that we need to find ways of encouraging
if it's an encouragement or a
negotiation or whatever it is you know
we need to finding ways of lobbying
government more on this issue but you
know there's a number of things there in
the discussion to be aired I think
everyone agrees with that I think I
think it's very much clear across party
issue and I think we're all very very
keen on finding ways to be improve our
green and greenness is there such would
you I think it's worth I was speaking to
the developers because if a developer
wants to sell a house one of the aspects
of its early is about how much that
energy cost of there is going to be an
into the future of course our energies
possibly will rise so the greenery -
it's in the developers interest to try
and get a good sale if you like because
it has the right insulation and the
right energy-saving virtues going
forward so I think it's in the
developers own interest to make it's
been a game it's also good for any
affordable housing of course because
people they're on mr. Richard incomes
perhaps there's a challenge there to
find out so basically one is put the
report together from the minutes of the
meetings that the group of had we don't
drive the committee's already had two
reports
on ICT and this was reckoned to be the
final report so I went back and put
everything together the group many times
enough when they met was on the 20th of
March and at that point they had a draft
of the report then they have the minutes
from that meeting never proved the
report as was and they came up with two
recommendations which I've listed down
there most of the discussions were
actually very amicable I think the main
thing that sort of come out that was the
council taken the cautious approach and
the group appreciated that and the
knowledge that was a right approach and
didn't feel that yeah speedy approach to
it would have helped any they're going
to remember they were just looking at
the migration from with edges of the
vibration thing for the cloud it wasn't
so much the movement to office 365
although that did get discussed and is
covered in the report
I don't think I've got anything else to
say but I'll answer any questions if I
can just under three point nine only
repeats itself I notice it says there's
no handle of information infrastructure
US troops cactus it's registered as
under the form of contract this was kept
at his property so to me it was their
intellectual property that they had
hundred bucks was there amazing that
there was no offer if you like they need
in intellectual property and me with a
contract that we have with a juicer is
there a similar clause so if we were to
go onto a different supplier then we may
have a problem with a juicer yeah the
way I understand it capture walked away
with their scripts given in your back we
therefore had to start from scratch we
contract with edge you serve I think I'm
right in saying we are not buys out good
yeah we learned from that yep and the
building so we've got those intellectual
property rights yes but the other women
say was was there any other night you
know to actually though as you say
intellectual property
but he had some questions but I'm not
sure like the answered really and then I
can all ask questions expected but also
like to buy you know often email the
questions which might be more
appropriate I don't know I'm not sure
that all will know the answers
necessarily email need them and I'll get
the answers for a few minutes even in
the other members so far is it because
I'm what I want to know I'm writing it
clinically and they're they're varied
and basically what you said some of the
Mahdi as I described the report even
though it was mentioned quite
extensively with all faculty the young
issue says about four five questions
that cover their three subjects the
first one is why didn't we manage to
retain the on-site contractor it seems
quite key to me was it around
communication was it around the fact
that were there where that there be no
god he got another job causing a
contractor well he worked the capture at
the time yeah and before he was to Peter
crossed he went to work in London
whether there was for more money I don't
know we didn't we weren't able to find
out why for him because of the way
people work people they work for us yes
yeah okay the next question if it's
around something I've been on time
children about this one it's about
because these answers questions for me
on it already looks about
software because I was be concerned in
the executive around the timing of the
urgent decision and I've noticed in the
report this was mentioned certainly in
the 5th of October report the Academy
software being an issue and possibly as
one of the ones referred to in the July
2018 report as well so I just need to
know if that if that was the case that
we knew at that point and it seems very
clear from this report that we did know
that Cudney Academy software was a
something that couldn't be migrated over
would have to go to the capital service
but it's more confirmation that was the
case at that time that was that one some
just released you take office 365's and
within the grounds of what they were
looking at but can we just go [ __ ] is it
or isn't it yeah migrated over because
report even greater ease but I'm not
sure it is and report says it was a
certain number is I've just have what
two point one where it says the
council's dangerous systems have been
transferred but that's not really very
true and that wasn't being transferred
with the office three eight seven point
five point six the second three point
six three and at that time 75 staff had
been driven over to six five probably
still some revs and Benz yeah we are or
still being transferred
that's what I'm pleased November 18 on
the for the blame for anything not all
staff Jim I mean not all staff had yet
gone over three six five nurse because
there's a dependency between you know
the sort of office systems and
some of the big big the big software
packages and those are those are you
know new new they nearly at the point
where they will be transferred across
the last one is now going to be the
Academy system which I think from the
penis reports is September this year so
it will be the last one but that's
that's the reason that's all static we
can provide not the end all your big
risk I don't know to procure well I'm
guessing there won't be an update the
reports gonna just talk more then Street
which actually I assume the first one
models if we have really there's gonna
be a continued review anyway money to
the movie anyway schimper figure that
will comfort me that which about this
theme we do need to know the actual
costs there were three quit my citrus I
do not know the cost of the moment that
we will know at some point what the
overall costs will be much we'll make
sure that split up in any comments yeah
and the last put on race please
beneficial being on 220 sometimes those
three point one nine is about the we
have Barbies here waiting for the South
America councils by the opieop I
understand you're from the Alden
committee understand that report had to
be done at the last Audit Committee the
report had been prepared and submitted
not yet fully reviewed but there was
some doubts over whether or not it
answered the questions we want to answer
I I think that's his executive decision
we're still in evolution yeah because
there was thoughts that we may have to
get someone else in to do the work it
that has made my by that report I think
that mean I think that may be the case
but I think we do no come back on that
so that complete yeah something from the
make sure is noted for the yep whoever
is on the working voltage yeah just a
quick addition if we get an update on
how many people have transferred okay
on this matter 7.6 3.0 it makes a
prediction 90 percent of the standard
would still remain by July not pay on on
whether they're still confident that's
the case at the same time oh no just a
suicide mr. chairman I'm pleased
slightly appropriate there still seems
to be every week there seems to be
trouble we done over the telephones or
the only team member staff members are
saying something's not working or the
things aren't working so this migration
seems to have been causing a lot of
disruption to the council's working I'm
sure you agree with that Ruth what I'm
concerned about is the staff it must be
very frustrating for the staff and I
wondered if we're taking that into
account because it must be very
difficult for them after I've worked in
an industry where you rely on technology
but if it's not working it's totally
frustrating and I just think that we
should bear bear that in mind and I'm
sure the managing director will be doing
something and hopefully it will be
resolved sooner rather than later miss
Bob I mean I've been to a number of
these meetings now and when we've had
contracts and the name of capital HD
server and always I mean only in bed
with the right people for what
I'm not being funny but we just seem to
go from we think we've done that bit and
then we go somewhere else and we seem to
take a step forward and a step back I
don't know if it's just me bottom see
another paper here not exactly the same
assessment the I'm sorry I say this
isn't my world I'll be the first to
admit it but it's a fair project isn't
it yes how do we make sure that we're
going down the right Road with the right
people I can use the a simple question
because we've been now going through
this cancer my similar self 103 years
something like that it's I think it's
been the Politis work that says a
disaster from conception to where we are
now but having said that we have to do
what we can to resolve it and I
certainly think it's something that we
need a group to continue to an overview
because there are so many issues and
difficulties and complex situations that
need examination yeah I mean perhaps I'm
just emphasizing that there need to keep
this working party going yes I know I
mean if you leave more than three but
it's certainly not my world forms it
yeah just to back to what you've come to
on yes I did recognize that there was
concerns that I had around the IT the
reason I've created a full
older for 18 but one or two other things
to do as well but predominantly OIT on
the basis that with IT it's two also
arrives question that it's never going
to end
because IT will be continuously be
updated as the years go by every year
there'll be new updates for various
programs new programs coming out so it
is an ongoing and continuous process
you've only got to think about your own
computer for a home I switch - the same
names just before I came here the first
thing you did was another updates the
computer that I have from County at the
moment is still running on Windows 7
we're waiting for the new update for
that for winters tape you know so which
means you make sure they don't be quite
a consumable never computers to do so it
is an ongoing process all the time and
will get more and more complicated as
time goes by my background is I see I
work I see what currently monitors to
make the mobile apps in 2017 which I
believe was after all of this all of us
started we did a migration to Microsoft
to do us by my day job took three months
I obviously would have been as big of
complexes as I'm guessing the systems I
hit my initial sceptical fear was to the
point I see will continue to move on and
as for people looking to exploit
opportunities should we say in people
that don't fully understands and however
I was those skeptical thoughts were put
to bed when reading this report when
when seeing that we did actually stick
to the original budget they won't pay
for the time period they were paid for
the work delivered and but yeah it is
worthwhile iting that this work doesn't
usually take this long and I think there
are chances for to learn lessons and if
there were to be a working group
continued
I think learning some of those lessons
and make sure we don't repeat them in
the future would be call to tasks very
quickly chairman young nominate
counselors feel that I just wanted to
ask you one thing
um three point one knowing on the post
of employment break when we have this
failure the last time this brought
before the committee they said that they
were going to go on educators
compensation if they do that yes I would
have to ask yeah you don't know I knew
you wouldn't know it but I just asked
the question
I don't remember if they mentioned no I
mean I with working group oh I can't say
I'm not disputing yeah it was mentioned
in November bug don't remember the
working group actually challenged
anything that and getting that
information so but okay do so I can take
that okay it was um there are two
recommendations Englishman from
this thing that technical folks separate
for now the first recommendation
it's proposed that the committee
recommends that the project we continue
to monitor the migration and associated
costs to completion I know it was insane
you will know about the agenda further
on the next item I think it might be
best to agree these recommendations now
and then on the next item discuss so
members in agreement with recommendation
one group recommendation to that it also
have some capacity from MIT changes
project group attached to the asset
delivery transformation project should
take on responsibility to monitor the IC
team post migration to make sure the two
projects are connected
[Applause]
[Applause]
mr. Khanna suggests that for the
benefits of newer members you elucidate
the normal procedures that we have so
that that they're aware of the
commitments that we have anyway as a
review committee because otherwise
there's a danger that we're going to do
so much that nothing will get done so if
you could allow if you could inform the
members of the especially for the
benefit the new members the actuals that
we have to do as a matter of negation
and then we can fill in the blanks so
porn I discussed this today so I don't
think those items
well they're roughly ready to go as I
always do but commit you have three
Treasury reports each year that are
submitted the end of year which will be
in July then the half yearly report
which comes in December and then the
strategy for the following year which
will be January over here okay in
addition to those three reports you will
have a report from the Community Safety
Partnership now sometimes we have two a
year but the regulations say we have to
have one because in addition to your
other roles you are the crime and
disorder committee your designated is
there so we have that one we then have
Ripper which comes in October which is
basically covert surveillance
[Music]
regulation of Investigatory Powers Act
mm I'd think about what refers to I'm
sorry Akron is the must just roll in the
count so I'm afraid I think you've gotta
fight first I love it
no he's just my honestly like that that
comes and we had an inspection last year
we did well on that inspection but we
had to produce a social product or
social media policy to go alongside that
month but this year it was just looking
at and amending any roles that have
changed yes Oh Constitution was one that
got mentioned last year and that had to
be added that's probably gonna be about
Marcus just an ongoing one it would be
just an annual review that will come
just for a check before it goes to
council rather than this the long
drawn-out process that we had before yes
don't think there's any other ones that
I know about you know council stepped
I've mentioned emergency plan we've had
that a number of poems that would just
be usually a meeting we'd have an
officer presented go through it as long
as members are happy then that's fine
that's as far as it goes so it's just
one meeting
yeah I think we'd had to bet has the
Granville Taylor disaster and it was
basically trying to make sure that we
were covered and had something in place
that was foreign State yeah no research
Aaron can I just suggest that we do put
that on to the work plan I'm sure that
that's something that we ought to keep
know because standards don't change
things alter and as the officers said
it's not particularly onerous but it is
something that should be updated
wrinkling there's just a couple things
we children do we look at some low area
outside contractors like cito et cetera
and they are a supplier as well do we
not being used to have I mean just
asking about you know the their
contracts are going any any problems
with the buildings et cetera
I don't know if that was a costly yeah
we've done it in the past we have done
it for a couple of years but there's no
reason why we could be invited in the
yellow I'm saying and just give us a
summary how they see things yeah Nevers
can ask questions if they have those
specimens I think we see to that there
is an ongoing change now there is a
regular at least quarterly meeting with
the area reps here district managers
know this whole thing where all these
issues are pulled out if they are
considered necessary I think we wait
until there's an issue of it's an
ongoing conversation all the time
- councilman fearsome Thank You chairman
and it was literally just on the Mexican
Consulate Randolph said about the
contract is it worth us looking at
contracts over certain value or tell
they are tempted commissioned inclusive
of things like the social value act that
sort of thing statutory we you know you
don't really get a choice you actually
put it out to tender I would disagree in
some respects because I rarely see the
social value included as much as it
could be in some of the contracts we've
got our tour miss Kelson I would even
mention this dancer would have their
peculiar walking they've put in I
suppose the next contract is say two
years here so they I think in the
posture committee required of attention
to we all serious towards it when we
have this new contract this Sita we
spend a lot of time on that one over
year but Chris Tanev downstairs but
weird Krishnamurti was heavily involved
I think he might be another one human
he's a if one that can cause you
problems
yeah big problems
council can't move and remember when the
original 2007 death yeah I've just
started in the council and it was big
problems when it was rolled down now
yeah
the camp that the committee might want
to look at that and I don't think the
assistant director would be at first to
perhaps do something that can use be
explored yeah I think the next contract
isn't going to be very straightforward
for a variety of issues I think there's
some government legislation coming
forward as well which might change it
well and also the the issue is pretty
regard to the money back basis that we
used to get for County that I could
happen what we shall start recycling the
exam areas we used to get paid yeah to
recycle then we have the party policy
process there was problems on the
contract plastic disposal so now so yeah
no one wanted to tender for it yeah
we've just had to renew it for a year so
there are a lot of issues there
definitely so if we can find out when
the contrast coming up I can certainly
talk to the assistant director and see
if he would wish to have assistance from
the committee or
okay counsel mr. Hoyt sorry he was on
the back of that radium it was on the
recycling site or anything as
interesting talk Tiffany and I thought
you've only written to our last night on
BBC one about plastic being exported to
Malaysia I'm not sure if anyone know is
a way around this table that we have
under our contract or is it an open I'm
gonna die hearing was even I that to
hurt me the name of them but physically
the last email I had to say that we do
export some of our plastic to Malaysia
so that there could be some concerns of
they are my understand that was really
that was up renewing made though I
understand German that some of the
plastic through you some of the classes
will use there as she make into things
like cardigans and so it sure things
like that because that's not doing tools
to do that
so they're not use it under significant
and it's the only other thing is gym is
cheaper to ship it out there because
there's a lot of products coming this
way there's not a little oil price going
the other way so this actually cheap
passage to actually get it on another
ownership to them exactly where the
right members absolutely right it's
about where it actually ends oh yes and
that's what we need to look tempo right
I think it's in our own public entry
since the ever actually dictator mr.
chairman it but they don't counsel
employees is wrong it's and it is mine
then we is actually a very short time
span to look at that contract is a
complex contract it's difficult so I do
think that's something that this
committee should look at because there's
the reputational risk as well as we
heard from another council being slated
on the media because they waste had
ended up in
there's certainly we don't want to have
that but for both for the environmental
issues which council Steptoe has said
that he's came to look at and also from
look at the cost issues there's a lot of
issues there that need to be addressed
finally through chairman it's not so
much where it ends up there it's what
they do with it against there anything
and that's it i think there's also these
you come on this one is what the options
are that we will have in front of us and
that he's gonna I think probably
potentially be the biggest issue you
know this at this price are you can I
face on it and the knock-on effect will
be whether you can do this the customer
for the residents of this or this or
this or how it works so that is going to
be a straightforward right now yeah
there are also I'm pretty sure that the
the offices are that it's not just a
quiet Australia cool let's just look at
the contrast finally all bits and pieces
of that well over two thousand seven
three new chairman you know there were
so many different facets that we could
have done we actually chose what
actually work for his crews was a simple
one yeah and that's our look we managed
to get the recycling rates that we have
because we have a simple system whether
you'll be able to have that in the
future is another point yeah and at what
cost
that's the thing as well it's astounding
for instance you don't charge great
waste lots of many other councils do or
they were or in the process of
introducing it so you know that's
something that he's looking at you know
do we continue to do that we certainly
have no plans to do it at the moment so
you know
when you say that and this program about
plastic that we're watching last night
but they're doing so doing this trial
yeah and it's it's supposed to reduce
like the counts or Safety Council money
and what it what they're doing is that
they've gone and by their weekly
shopping yeah and then because what they
found out is that if you buy a single
Apple and you buy a pack of apples a
pack of apples real way to be cheaper
than buying a single Apple so so what
they did they went into this Tesco's
extra store
I thought we their food walk out
unpacked it took all the plastic out of
it filled it all back up into their
trolley and took the trolley back into
the supermarket because the supermarket
then has to get rid of it sort of things
so I you know I mean I'd be bit I mean
they're trying it for I think it's the
trial in it's two weeks just building on
from what you're exploring with the
contracts TerraCycle do a recycling
system so plastics that aren't currently
restarted by the council
they will provide containers and they do
pay for what they're taken away so crisp
packets and biscuit packets things that
we're currently not recycling they do
and I'm wondering if the council will
consider a sweetums having a another
recycling system set up we've already
got bottled and some research
we have discussed point of the grouse
switch ever that cross-coupling medical
directors basically new development is
that new developments on aren't odd new
developments will be catered for by a
private management company now so public
open space will be in the hands of the
residents of the area where that young
tada now we've had many from Charles
took off the open spaces so to me is a
is looking at that with a next good idea
or a bad idea but I think that I think I
was probably one of the better brace
this because we're gonna wind up with
you there's a District Council we're
going to end up with is my AIA my view
toys that we gain at a ground that start
because we know these companies sorry
historically they just disappear after a
couple years and we intellect with
whatever's there
so my view was that we gained both the
start when there is money being offered
to do do well we take that because
ultimately we will have to take over the
grass cutting but by then we'll have the
rights and the bits and pieces from the
residents and you also find that with
these management companies about three
trips down the after cup of sales people
don't read the small print and suddenly
they find out as we can go around the
district and find that there's all these
places that nobody knows who owns the
trees nobody I was on is this ditch and
if we had been involved at the outset at
least
would have some responsibility or some
knowledge of what's going on there but
we've got flood issues potentially I can
think of one down where I was playing
where there is a whole raft of trees and
the company I believe is by somewhere in
Scotland in and has gone out of business
but we can't do anything because we
don't know whose tree sale I have every
sympathy with countless fairings
proposal and I do think they want to
look at this but I do think he's also
wrong in some respects the management
companies that are being set up now
they will not fold because they are
making profits and there is a difference
between the historical silence where
I've been involved with some reasons
where you the company has you're quite
right
disappeared and there's a piece of land
that no one owns to the new developments
where it's a really tight legal
situation but I do agree that they're
under satisfactory and I do think that
they're fundamentally flawed and I do
think it's something we should look at
some welcome that going on so they
worked one example of that chairman I
think it was actually pointed out by you
my perhaps at the time is in the Bray's
Lane the roundabouts just but you've got
a little bit in the middle and nobody
had responsibility for cutting it it
wasn't part of the landscaping area of
the yeah it should have been it has been
adopted by highways but also along that
sonics it's not quite clear but about
six inches of the merge
belongs to the highways and the rest
belong to the estate so I think that's a
sort of you're not getting to experience
study counted a mistake maybe which some
may know called the birds to stay
it's got coudl green areas and come from
two or three companies of water setup we
paint into as a resident in fact I still
know people paid into bank accounts that
they're not even sure who these bank
accounts belonging the ideas of
residential involvement as we're sounds
good okay it's basically a double charge
of the residents leave home council tax
and they're paying a private company to
be doing later on in the year there's an
agenda item have enough time and what
they've done and then decide from there
people are buying electric cars so it's
important and we provide them with a
charging point to encourage them and are
we seeing there's money to be made in it
Somali pop in a car you know like in
Georgia car at the same time which
sounds sensible to me and I think a lot
of people would pay a lot of money to do
that I think that's already I think we
were striving for the point that was at
Planning London the last planning
meeting so I don't think that's
discussions I guess the clarity I'm
after is is the scope of this again from
my background work have a little bit of
interest in kind of on street parking
and preparing urban areas for the future
needs of life space may look like in the
future and how it may be used and it's
this specific off street parking and car
parks is from you or was this
possibility for us to look into that
aspect of on street parking and
provision and then the second piece was
around very very linked and the previous
comment and also a continuation of that
theme and I don't know if we're aware of
taking electric vehicle charging one
step further that there's concepts where
you can start paying back into the grid
from from your vehicle and these type of
things would require purpose base
infrastructure on on the street so I
guess what I'm really looking for it's a
comp all circles the clarity of the
scope of this sites and are we very
specific
of street parking needs there are
certain opportunities with your on
street right we as a council now I only
have control of off street parking
okay um a few years ago and I can't
actually give you the year it's taken
back by this so they do all on the
street and it's a group North Essex and
South Essex but our remit is basically
Street office rates people you know and
that's the only bit we have control over
like just clarify that I mean we do have
been taught about as one council out of
all the cell physics authorities so is
that these are seventeen celebrities
that are in trouble
southeast is bar Point C which have
baked in Chelmsford but we do have a
word you know if you like we're one of
the number so that's only for our own
area week week so having any influence
shall we say I think that's the only
Avenue that we take yeah but as you say
it's a partnership so I think you're but
I think we get parking TV has insisted
on it but it's yes control now having
before that clarity is much appreciate
so we know who represents us as as part
of our initiative
it was councilor stepped oh girl no
showing is near I think he's doing
I think you're yes he is thank you all I
can say is we with the car parking fees
most areas where they've got electric
points you pay one or the other if
you're paying for an electric charge or
your vehicle you don't pay car parking
charges so in the charge for the
election you're paying for that meter to
charge your car
in the PHR me we should be looking at
complex private spaces are they suitable
for purpose we need more do we need
nurse are they the right configuration
sorry it was a bit like no it's another
sort of their Mercedes sorry I apologize
on the next big note a quite a lot
already
I'm not sure all I meant was how much
probably feeling or polishing she felt
don't want to make the I'll make sure
they clean I do not think actually Bell
against the leader the big nice comes
with you because they're both fairly
look very good if we figured 18 months
ago then we're going to review it with
suggestions but no it's so far along
maybe I think it comes in after yeah
just like yeah exactly but not as as
just as mister I said it's too light to
come in too
that chasm abysm I mean chairman Issa's
opportunity to put items forward for
designation
so are we rolling out the 20/20 thing
that's happening in this two years ago
and I'm going back a few years we used
to regularly get the RSPCA book print
award for our animal welfare
we have no animal welfare officer and
yet there has been recent changes in the
work and law have ranked and I just
wonder if we could review that I may be
in the only person but we often get
reports of dog attacks loose dolls and
people just don't I don't know if we're
moving away from people actually still
looking after their dogs and
understanding the legalities around what
we can do as a council to enforce the
know yeah and look at animal welfare
which also comes under responsibility
comes a little Chairman 3 we actually
never their warfare strategy I don't
know if you're aware but so we actually
have a document that sits there and it
might be worth just having a look and
reviewing that there is some new
legislation coming out as well and the
hasn't been passed yet it was
anticipated to be passed around about
April time it hasn't as soon as it is
passed the monitoring of you is going to
issue a briefing paper and then later on
in the year there will be training so I
think we'd be jumping the gun slightly
on that because that the law is actually
changing and there's big there's a whole
new graph you know that that's coming
out and it's it's included as we know in
the committee's so whilst I think it's
quite a very important point I think
it's something that we could perhaps put
on the back burner until we see what
happens with the legalities
because we'd be wasting our time
whatever we decided reside
changed I rise it for later in the year
them yeah I mean after suggestions every
day I mean I think I think if we
actually got diesel machines we don't
need to pipe a pipe but that would like
us a bit green army I was fine I'm sorry
but I would say we're all people coming
before us Michelle for paper well we've
got machines that tonight that's under
the IT with you again yeah it is but
it's like you know we've got another if
you make small mistakes
it makes bigger strikes at the cost of
paint our printing we did it I tweeted
this format company and we save fortunes
we're just doing this the whole point of
that machine exactly fortunately the
machines don't work everywhere that's
right we're talking about these cups
that I fight the homeless it's a hundred
one phone 99
yeah but the paper is easily recyclable
plastic is I think we're losing the
point okay so this ends in a comment it
seems that the most important thing at
the moment would be for the council to
set an example yes the review would
focus on what the council is currently
doing in gossipy inside the offices
we have to find out what we're using
first before we desire to reduce it
expanded field through you I think it
needs to these enduring quality of yours
oh that's another area I think there
might be something might be over several
years I'll do then is I'll take it light
plane to bring against Mariko subject
yet it's a smaller bits
yeah and areas constructions are going
on now well what the limitations are
that we can do I mean we may say we want
this this this is this and the developer
says well actually legislation doesn't
support that you can we can reduce this
exact so we've got to find that stuff
out booming ability we can't decide what
we want on it we can if it's a
cost-effective yeah and then they say it
may be that we say no yes it is but it
saves money yeah okay well I think a few
bits for now but obviously any other
system
any meeting just point on trying to have
a small focus and I do think because of
the work people like David Attenborough
through really fine soon television
programs the council is fully atmosphere
that mentioned there may be an
opportunity to for good PR of the back
of our recycling records to to hold a
review on quite specifically the
council's use of single-use plastics and
I think that does feel like they're
quite self-contained and focus piece of
work that we use to review I don't know
how we feel about I think that was thank
you very much
so yeah
captain new pool was on the group
originally and then obviously not is see
so he wasn't on last year but is
indicated is winning this back on
something I think mr. chairman with his
expertise we need you know it's also
like councilor canning in people agreed
to go on I think he his expertise would
be you know is something that there's no
limits
oh no no no what say I'm just thinking I
know what the sign Mustaine was because
Kris will say himself for he's the IT up
then that he will tell you that
sometimes you need something like that
oh yeah yeah you know because who knows
I'd say we need just know that hasn't
got the experience of ICT we'll look at
it very differently and sometimes that
should we say more basic approach or
more user friendly approach will help
people to see who sometimes their
expertise makes things look simple when
actually to the majority of us it's not
simple
with this before and the the reasons I
didn't join immediately when I joined
the council whilst we briefly had a
similar social more so timing of the
meetings and if that could be resolved
and yes I Oh
so I'm not resolved but if they were
clear in advance and they were on the
same day on each occasion which I'll
beautiful aperitif all and there may be
ways to make sure for the 10 those
meetings but if it was a sprite time as
a movie you know may not the group had
been meeting during the day but there's
no reason why they couldn't meet in the
evening if we want to take this outside
of the meeting and let me know your
availability you know yeah if we can
take this in theory I have no mr.
chairman can I make one suggestion
councillor sparing has a lot of business
acumen it's not it's not my world I'm
sorry well I know but I wasn't sure if
you'd be interested in I think I think
we need yeah yeah I understand we but
it's really not my world
I mean my question tonight is to pay off
my limit yeah thank you
well my case someone I not perhaps
understanding mighty but understanding
other aspects would be equally useful
for stands
a subcommittee sometimes it might be
something we could take away forever
yeah yeah just somebody yeah yeah it's
not also mr. chairman at least working
groups aren't political and I think that
comedies me that the chairman said they
wanted something the conservative the
Chairman I think was wrong in saying
that because working groups are not
meant to be Parata they're not meant to
be political they're meant to me for
people who have the ability and the
willingness to do the work and to say
that you're taking away and discussing
in a group meeting it's fundamentally
flawed it's a decision for this
committee not for a political group I
think
please know that the green group haven't
requested anyone on this committee not
quite happy with the representatives on
the other moment even though we don't
represent ourselves that's making it
political I'm sorry to say that it
should be a conservative member I have
no objection to a conservative member
goannas group but I do have an objection
to the conservative group determining it
and not this committee but they could be
members are here if one of them wants to
put their name forward absolutely fine
but no problem with that
I didn't have came to it being three
liberals on there I do need them
probably make a team right now
and I don't see why you know it's
working group the two to the Liberals
aren't even on here I have no objection
to that so it's not political I think
your future leaders of this community I
think you missed the point mr. chairman
the decision should be taken here not at
a conservative group meeting you have
all but one I believe of
your conservative members on here if one
of them wants to put themselves forward
but that's an individual that the
committee have decided that those
individuals can be nominated to those
positions it's not what you're
suggesting a conservative let them
decide who it is I'm sorry I strongly
object you're bringing politics into
this committee which we're trying not to
do it I don't like to give me an email
that helps we won't we may there may be
some fingers that somebody's not gear
who has some expertise if I could offer
who's not here on the committee uh yeah
any of them I mean caster Stanley's not
here this who I'm saying there may be
somebody else who would have something
to contribute who is not here you
suggested me I haven't got anything - in
that case it comes back to the committee
it is not up to a group decision that's
the middle of game - she's not up to the
conservative group to decide who goes on
this committee what's going on there I
see no reason why we can't put forward
the dominations now for the working
policy working group but it has been
cold there's no nothing stop us of the
next meeting I think we've done that
even the past
working party strength rarely is around
here sometimes being able to affect it
there's no bother me if there is someone
the night before my another broom or
something they can do that for the next
week yeah that makes me anything
some of these men start yeah and that's
probably quite appropriate as we're not
we're not absolutely sure yet if remain
continue to start with and then run
tonight meeting and counter use once
once of the green what is going to be
will probably be immediate to start with
and then possibly
thank you just take what you said about
the cross or cutting on right did you
say that was coming in this country just
cancer community to start because I
think it's quite it's quite a big policy
decision on yeah think that would need
to be made I think it already goes
beyond trust I you me too
yeah eventually but after the first
meeting the waking going to hold I
didn't either
when you can see the scope of it yeah I
think that's that's a difficulty with a
lot of these until you've actually seen
the scope know what they're gonna do and
pick strands from it then it's difficult
near so working economic leverage the
key decisions document
okay first one to nineteen environmental
health service plan twenty nineteen
twenty seven so Gladys point one point
as far as the King decision for
committee is concerned and it's
something I have raised before with
offices but they've been very down it
can we put a date on it please there's
no dates for the actual conclusions and
things that are very on there there's
not actually on the book oh no no all
right I did before but he's never right
I'll make sure this is actually what
ladies work really yeah
and then a number is well time - oh we
I'll put it on the cracker sorry to
interrupt you when you got that okay
let's say the first one environmental
health service plan it should have been
by the end of my marketing promises me
and I've I've seen it circulated for
comment already they should go out
Friday I think there's been a few
holdups when people didn't waver
as I say this Friday it should be a
number 419 place basis improvement plan
that meant that our big successes these
we've seen that before
519 benefits cloud service water again
went to exactly last week and was
mentioned mr. chair that was the
clarification on that I understand that
the officer won't be able to answer this
now but I would like an answer coming
back to this committee as to what caused
that item to be an item that could not
be called in it was went to the
executive and they said that because of
the it was not subject to calling
because of the time factor we need an
explanation of why that time factors
slipped because it should have been
subject to cooling and could we have
that explanation just circulated in
writing please unless you want to bring
it back to the next committee if I may
block on that just for the confirmation
of dates it was known about at least on
the piece of October so it's known about
prior to the 5th of October 2018 and
possibly at the July 2018 working group
meeting it's only a year
who needs that we need to understand
what failed in the process to call so
it's be such a very urgent decision okay
thank you right 619 awarding in the
banking contract to get an embassy exact
last week in one
come to the two new ones 790 planning
enforcement plan basically I believe the
assistant director placed environment is
trying to sort out you know what they
will enforce my priorities for the
enforcement a because the number of
cases they've got oh my god
and then the last one 819 measurement
cultural services strategy and then
they're trying to sort out the ongoing
strategy that is so likely to feeding to
the little bit of contractors little
boys and that's why they're there now
trying to put in a strategy so then some
that will feed into the next contract
because I don't see the McLean they're
changing and coming out from there as we
know in the fright so it just should
just be the letter sent to say any
questions
thank you very much everybody